alain fonden président de l'association
française des maîtres restaurateurs et
annick fraiser les médecins généralistes
et vice président de l'union régionale
des professionnels de santé médecins
libéraux rhône alpes
messieurs bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france alors yannick
fraiser vous êtes médecin on le sait
désormais trop vacciner il n'empêche pas
d'être contaminés de contaminer
d'ailleurs est ce que c'est bien cela
oui c'est ça le vacciner c'est une
protection vis-à-vis de ce virus
physalies cette épidémie vis-à-vis des
cas graves et des formes graves que nous
pouvons développer mais cela n'empêche
pas pour remettre le couvert si on peut
dire sur le débat dans ce moment on le
masque l'intérêt du port du masque
puisque vous pouvez être vaccinés et
malgré tout être porteurs
asymptomatiques du virus est risqué de
le transmettre donc le vaccin est une
protection nécessaire mais pas que en ce
moment à la fontaine notre président de
l'association française des maîtres
restaurateurs depuis la mise en place
elle ne sait pas ce sanitaire saugeraies
vous chiffrez ont donné une fourchette
du manque à gagner qu'il a représenté
pour les restaurateurs
oui notamment précision je suis pas
saint-martin-la-plaine je suis amélie
coach et un confrère les chiens rouge
dans l'oise un très bon sens mais alors
on a fait un sondage chez les maîtres
restaurateurs on a effectivement que des
tribus du pass samedi la mise en place
du center on a eu une baisse jusqu'à 34%
dans certaines régions alors bien sûr
les choses avec le passing terre qui
avança vaccination se sont calmées après
il reste des régions qui sont impactés
mais pas à seulement paraît pas
sanitaire si vous voulez le passage
était à fait partie d'un panel de
d'événements qui impacte effectivement
la restauration donc elle passe ses
terres mais aussi les visioconférences
qui nous bloque un peu les repas
d'affaires il ya effectivement le
télétravail il ya un certain nombre
d'événements comme ça qui se
qui se met en place et qui effectivement
dans certains sites paris lille orleans
est très claire ly le sujet il est très
clair c'est que vous avez des gens qui
assoient 20 minutes à peu près de la
frontière belge où il n'ya pas de passes
sanitaire et ils vont manger
effectivement en belgique donc vous avez
aussi des sites qui sont je dirais
qu'ils sont impactés 2 par leur
positionnement paris est impacté par le
manque de tourisme on n'a pas d'eau on
n'a pas la clientèle chinoise s'ils ne
peuvent pas rentrer puisque le vaccin
n'est pas reconnue par les autorités
françaises les nos amis japonais qui eux
ont une baise ont une vaccination que tu
aux alentours de 10% dont il rentre pas
et là mais et les états unis qui sont
entrées en zone orange et tout de suite
les tour-opérateurs ont vu une baisse
des demandes de voyages en france on
voit là le pass center fait partie d'un
ensemble de choses qui effectivement
sereine sur certains sites la
fréquentation c'est très clair c'est
entre -10 à -34 % c'est effectivement le
sondage qu'on a fait la semaine dernière
yannick fraiser si la vaccination
n'empêche pas la contamination est ce
que le pass à nanterre a toujours tout
son sens
bien sûr que le passé littérature son
sens si on l'a vu moi j'entends tout à
fait comme dans votre reportage les gens
qui considèrent que c'est une atteinte à
la liberté que 7 h un suivi de notre
personne de notre activité de nos
mouvements sage l'entente tout à fait je
suis un homme un papa un citoyen un
humain et je subis exactement les mêmes
choses que moi je le vois différemment
bien sûr c'est mon côté médical les
médecins qui porte cette voie mais je le
vois comme un outil protecteur il faut
pas oublier que nous sommes à cent vingt
mille morts aujourd'hui de cette
épidémie des dégâts économiques
votre interlocuteur via le dire qu'ils
sont considérables pour la plupart des
entreprises la plupart des milieux
professionnels et se passe sanitaire
c'est un moyen j'ai pas dit que c'était
le moyen j'ai pas dit que c'était
l'idéal mais c'est un des moyens de
pouvoir assurer malgré tout une
protection même si je les ai dit en
introduction on risque quand même le
transfert de virus même si on est
vaccinés mais 50 millions de personnes
protégées aujourd'hui sur la quatrième
vague nous n'avons pas eu d'explosion du
système de soins que ce soit au niveau
des établissements publics et privés que
ce soit en médecine de ville dont je
fais partie nous n'avons pas eu à
choisir des patients à l'entrée des
hospitalisations ce qui n'a pas toujours
été le cas sur les vagues précédentes
donc moi j'entends tout mais il est vrai
qu'il faut se replacer dans le contexte
d'une épidémie mondiale qui ferme les
frontières c'est vrai mais il ya un
moment il faut se recentrer sur nous
mêmes sur ce que nous pouvons offrir
comme suivi est prise en charge de santé
auprès des français auprès de la
population donc se passe sanitaires je
pense qu'il est important
quant au fait d'être suivie pour réagir
à votre documentaire tout le monde à
facebook instagram twitter tik tok où on
sait très bien toutes les données de
connexion sont suivies donc si vous vous
connectez sur ces domaines là vous avez
autant de suivi que le pass sanitaire
donc ce n'est pas un bon argument à
mettre en avant alain fontaine sans
passé ni terre sont a été la fermeture
des restaurants une nouvelle fermeture
ça aurait été pire en beaucoup de vos
collègues par exemple n'aurait peut-être
pas pu survivre
alors clairement les choses sont très
claires il faut bien s'il n'y avait pas
eu pas sanitaire voix seulement on
aurait dû fermer du moins c'était un
petit peu ce qui a été posé sur la table
avec le gouvernement entre les syndicats
et le gouvernement c'était le pass
center où la fermeture effectivement le
passé terre étaient le moins pire pour
nous et certains n'auraient pas pu vivre
par contre il faut quand même remercier
le gouvernement qui sait bien c'est bien
rendu compte de l'amplitude des dégâts
qui auraient pu avoir sur cette région
car toutes les régions ne sont pas au
même niveau ça vous avez au fin fond des
campagnes des restaurants qui marche
très bien on a du moins du cul 110 d'une
puce s'entendent plus 140 donc les
français ont vraiment voulu s'isoler
pour partager ce moment de plaisir cet
art de vivre dans les restaurants mais
dans certaines villes est incertaine
moyennes villes là oui c'était dangereux
les restaurants sont à bout de souffle à
bout de souffle économique et si on
n'avait pas eu l'aide de gouvernement on
aurait plongé et donc la refermeture
aurait provoqué une casse
supplémentaires cirque aujourd'hui je
pense qu'entre les moins 40 c'étaient
les 40% de fermeture qui avait été
annoncé en début début de la crise on
aura peut-être nos rares on aura
sûrement beaucoup moins de casse la case
se limitera et donc le passé terre est
effectivement le moins pire pour nous
mais il faut bien comprendre et je
réponds à votre interlocuteur que le
passé l'état est quand même pour nous le
grand écart il faut pas oublier quand
même que les restaurants sont un lieu
d'accueil d'art de vivre de plaisir et
c'est vrai que moi j'ai 63 ans donc
c'est la première fois que je demande un
peu les papiers aux gens donc c'est un
peu un peu bizarre c'est une saison
bizarre que l'on accepte mal gaza parce
que vous savez on a toujours appliqué
nous quand on ose affirmer le 14 le 14
mars 2020 le 29 octobre 2020 plus que
stop and go qu'on a fait pendant 19 mois
on a eu beau râler on a appliqué les
choses donc on les a appliqués même si
le passé à l'inter c'est pas la panacée
on l'a appliqué et les choses se passent
plutôt bien mais j'ai espoir dans le
discours de monsieur mac monde d'hier
qui a expliqué que le pass center sera
allégé petit à petit et surtout dans
certaines régions donc on va croiser les
doigts pour retrouver une vie normale
très rapidement parce que nous
franchement sur par amy notre ville on
attend on arrive à la fin de l'année et
vous savez que la fin de l'année pour
les restaurateurs avec les les repas de
fin d'année des entreprises avec les
réveillons et eau c'est une année très
importante
nous sortons de cette crise
définitivement qu'elle fasse partie de
notre passé le plus rapidement possible
et puis les choses iront bien mais c'est
vrai que
ont subi mais on applique ont subi mais
on applique messieurs merci à mon 2
d'avoir été là pour répondre aux
questions alain fontaine veut être
président de l'association française des
maîtres restaurateurs merci à vous et
annick fraiser vous êtes médecin
généraliste et vice président de l'union
régionale des professionnels de santé
médecins libéraux on ap merci à vous
tous